Module 4: Advanced Safety Topics and Emergency Procedures.
In this module, we'll cover advanced safety considerations
and emergency response procedures.
First, let's discuss load stability and center of gravity.
Every load has a center of gravity that affects forklift stability.
When the combined center of gravity moves outside
the stability triangle, a tip-over can occur.
In case of a tip-over, never jump from the forklift.
Stay seated, grip the wheel, and lean away from the fall.
For fire emergencies, know the location of fire extinguishers
and emergency exits in your workplace.
If your forklift catches fire, immediately shut off the engine,
evacuate, and alert others in the area.
Regular maintenance is crucial for preventing emergencies.
Report any unusual sounds, leaks, or handling issues immediately.
Remember to document all incidents and near-misses.
This helps prevent future accidents.
Safety is an ongoing commitment that requires
constant vigilance and continuous learning.